Hank I'm so excited that you are finally
able to be a guest on the podcast did an
episode of your podcast which I kept for
some reason thinking that you had been
on the podcast because we had done that
podcast but I don't come to Los Angeles
that often I live in Montana and so you
like to do it in real life with people
it's very true yeah it because it's I
think much more engaging no I agree it's
harder to do not in real life but also
Los Angeles is awful what is your
impression of Los Angeles when you come
here mm-hmm
are you doing like an actual impression
all right
good on you car get in there get in it
stay in the car
that's what it sounds like in my head
Wow it's like he's in the room yeah it's
really good yeah we spare no expense if
you could say anything to the Pope what
would it be
what's the longest fart you ever had I
would love to hear his answer I would
love I wish it would be like thank God
someone asks that I've been dying to
tell you who in the world alive or dead
would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti at does it have sauce on it
or is it just a nude it's entirely up to
you because it doesn't I always think
it's not a violent act it's just kind of
like sending someone a message a lot of
people said they want to throw it at
Tyler Oakley because I think he would
love it daddy I did once throw spaghetti
at a friend of mine in high school and I
being a uh-huh a thoughtless man sure
did not consider the effect that this
would have on my friends nice white
shirt and I basically lost a friend for
like a month
Wow okay so this has like there's no way
it was and then we like became friends
again this is I'm sorry I'm answering
the question I'll get there no it's a we
were later in a bouncy castle after we
had made up and we're friends again and
this was high school to be clear like a
schoolboy time throwing spaghetti then
getting in the bouncy cat
and she was she was bouncing up as I was
bouncing down and I landed on her hair
and she bounced up and I pulled out like
a like a hunk of her hair that like I'm
like like hundreds of hairs and I and I
look looked down and like saw the hair
like in my hand and I was like oh my god
I lost her for a month over the over the
spaghetti incident what's gonna happen
now and I was just panic and I was like
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry and she's like
it's okay was an accident it's okay and
I was like you serious like you you like
unfriended me from for a month over
spaghetti and she was like I cannot
believe that you cannot see the
difference everything was fine no we've
got that never yeah if I was cause like
it was clearly an accident and she was
fine with the accident but I threw
spaghetti sauce under her shirt it was
tension
people see the world in very different
ways and it's important that we
understand each other's differences how
many times have you hurt her since
physically and emotionally but I was
that friend to be like look we can be
friends but we just can't ever hang out
with each other anymore friends we're
friends because there's like a the
priest confessional wall behind it
between us we can talk but with it easy
the screen just by virtue of wanting to
be nearby a person I'd say Charles
Darwin oh I'd be like throw the Colts
forgetting I've been quick and some good
well I have your attention everyone over
got more about your upbringing in your
childhood and you're all right in your
difficulties just do a quick podcast oh
that is your equivalent of an evite is
throwing cold spaghetti at Charles
Darwin so he has a conversation tell us
about your worst pants [ __ ] story or
close call but you can only tell us in
three words or three small phrases okay
I I feel like the three smallest phrase
this is such a such a cop-out and I've
thought about this I've had several
different ones that it's since since I
listened to not too deep I'm like I have
so so many oh you're in good company
a lot of times people are like I don't
have a story I'll set your quiet lingo
oh really huh I have that life like okay
I please so there is this amazing thing
uh and the kid we're gonna go there
let's just do it yeah um is this your
story yeah I'm just gonna say my waffle
stomp my waffle stomp is your three
words my dude so so there's a thing
among people who have serious digestive
issues called the waffle stop oh my god
it's when you've accidentally pooped in
the shower oh my god you have to step it
down the damn it oh you have given me a
spectrum of education and I don't know
whether to thank you for it or not I'm
making a video
whoa whoa inception um grace yes I'm
getting people to try to laugh without
smiling oh this is odd okay I love
watching people do this I just pictured
Hannah doing this okay ready
Oh has anyone been successful at this
Flula was very good at it I'm sure he
has control over everything have you
done it
I have done it many times the thing that
we do in our office all the time is sort
of fun you just just laugh about smiling
yeah you may be the worst so far I could
like see myself as like a third party
doing it and I just knew it so dumb ah
this is a really great new way to make
friends if you're naming a dog pick
something that's in the emojis that's
true it makes it very easy to commute
dialed Oh lemon great daughter name yeah
or praise hands raised hands Helbig
here's
that would be amazing and then when they
write their name they just draw the
preys hands on their SATs